Boop now from here now I continued
bringing his rook to e3 and now Lodi a
really brought his knight into the
action he really wants to bring his his
Knight to d5 and put a lot of pressure
on this rook here but from here White's
going to go ahead and retreat his bishop
obviously top players don't wanna
exchange their bishops for knights and
black is now going to bring his Knight
to d5
now from here White has a nice little
move and if you want to go ahead and
pause it and look at it and this is
probably the defining moment in the game
later on you'll see a very important
move but this next move is very
important for white and its pawn to f3
and basically what this says is I'm not
planning on retreating I'm I'm a plan on
attacking the rest of the game and he
basically saw that if you wanted if
black were to come in and take this rook
then he could take with his bishop and
this black bishop right here on g2 is
trapped so he was basically willing to
trade this rook and his pawn for these
two minor pieces and anon saw that is a
win win so with that said black didn't
go for that right away instead he
brought his bishop down to before trying
to get more pieces into the action since
this bishop was just sitting back white
decided to go ahead and bring his King
to f2 again trying to attack this
LightSquared bishop there's nowhere for
this bishop to go now he is trapped in
here and blacks gonna go ahead and start
to give himself a little room and start
to trade off pieces and no longer is he
worried about giving up his bishop
because you just trading his bishop for
Knight and blacks going to go ahead and
take and the Queen's going to start to
gobble up pawns here and that's
completely ok with white because White's
going to bring his rook to b1 and start
to attack the King side over here well
the Queen side but he's going to start
to attack the black King blacks can
continue to gobble up pawns here
and the rooks going to come to b7 and
this is very important in time you're
playing a game a rook on the seventh
rank is very important it can just
gobble up pawns or pieces depending
what's on the seventh rank but a rook on
the seventh rank is very very strong so
this is why white allowed black gobble
up these two pawns in exchange for this
one pawn on b7 and seventh rank control
in the next move it here is really what
makes this game so memorable and it's
White's moving go ahead and take a
minute and if you don't find it it's
okay because the next move after this
move that we're going to talk about
right here is just as memorable so take
them if you want to pause it and see if
you can find what White's plan is here
and what actually moved h6 which got two
exclamation points if you're looking at
the the game board but this is an
amazing move because he's basically
giving up this pawn here and even if he
doesn't give up this pawn if he tries to
avoid it and come to g6 why it's going
to have the exact same plan because
after black takes on h6 then go ahead
and look at White's move if you want to
pause it real quick but white played
Bishop to g6 and this is a huge move
because what it does add a discovered
attack on the Queen so black has to do
something as far as because his Queens
in danger so he can either take what he
can either take this Queen or because if
he doesn't this Queen is going to be
captured or his other move is to take
this bishop and just lose his Queen or
we'll see he has a third option but if
he does take this plane and get greedy
then white can easily win the game here
well I say easily you could have won the
game but you probably want to play g6 if
you didn't see this next combination but
if black does take on d1 then you could
come to esis with your rook again this
pawn right here is pinned down because
of our bishop and from here the black
King would have to come to f8 doesn't
have any other legal moves and our
Bishop can come into the action again
this is our first time that we brought
our dark square Bishop into the game 286
here check
and after the black king comes to g8 his
only legal move then we can bring our
bishop to f7 and this is checkmate so if
the Queen does get greedy and comes down
to d1 and captures our queen then he's
going to lose the game
as we already talked about if he does
take our Bishop here then we can take
his queen so that's not very good but
there is one other move and that's what
Lodi a saw and that was bringing his
knight to e7 knowing that now he's
attacking this Bishop but at the same
time if we were to take his this Queen
then his rook is here and he can take
this as well but white saw this and he
said you know what that's exactly what I
wanted you to do he's going to go ahead
and take this and after he trades white
already saw that his position is
completely fine and he can anytime he
can take this bishop and be up in
material so from here white decided to
go ahead and start trading down he
brought his rook here to d3 any time
you're up in material you want to trade
down because his pieces start to come
off the board your advantage will become
more and more clear so white saw this in
and decided that he wants to go ahead
and start trading off pieces now black
decided that his King would be best on
d8 so he tried to save himself a move
because if instead he took then the
bishop would come down to d3 black again
remember wanted to bring his king to d8
it was kind of a moot point but instead
he brought his his rook to d8 and after
y captured on da pin
and the black Keene captured on da
excuse me and then the bishop came down
to d3 now it's black smooth but but he
is up another move if you wanted his
King on da now after the bishop came
down to d3 black resigned and if you
look at it here this bishop on d3 is now
safe and at the same time any if but
white wants to he can take this Bishop
on g2 any time he wants
as you can tell white will now have two
minor pieces he'll have a rook on the
seventh rank and this rook here on h8
has done completely nothing and it's
still out of the game they can get into
the game if it wants to but right now
it's not doing anything and why it's
going to have a pretty easy game here at
the GM level keep in mind any time you
have this sort of advantage at the GM
level it's normally a pretty easy win if
you're lower than the GM level which I
would assume most people are it can be a
little trickier but at the same time you
do have to LightSquared Bishop the game
is open there's not a lot of pawns in
the middle I mean it's going to be very
easier for you to control the rest of
the game this night here on e7 right now
is not going to do too much your king is
already starting to be centralized you
can start to bring it up the board with
III e4 and it's going to be really hard
for black to stop all the momentum that
you have here so in this case Lodi a
decided that the game was lost and he
went ahead and resigned so this is the
first video it's a two-part series to
video series because it was a little
longer than 10 minutes I try to go a
little bit in depth on each of the moves
that the GM's made here I'm going to be
going through again each of the the
games on my website and I'll try to make
them as frequently as possible but I
hope you guys enjoy the commentary on
this famous game if you haven't already
please subscribed and I'll see you guys
in the next video
thanks for watching